excusez aux jours des petites variantes
aujourd'hui on se trouve sur new york
times hockey est un jeu d'horreur
écouter j'avais envie un petit peu de
faire un caca culotte voilà
régulièrement une fois ma dose de kaka
culotte tous les mois où il passe comme
ça vous avez vu à tyr liban un pont sur
le chihuahua alors j'ai envie de jouer à
ce jeu parce qu'apparemment il est
[ __ ] de terrifiant mais voyez n'est
pas très bon à ce qu'ils ne touchent
pour interagir avec le décor j'en
absolument aucune idée bon alors
tombeuse j'avançais parti allait elle
facof ailleurs un moyen âge est en fait
croiser aujourd'hui par des bruits de
kaolin mais qui panique alors on va pas
en nous des ports est-ce qu'il va y
avoir une sorte de scream heures à un
moment il ya du sang olivier quelqu'un
saigner du nez très bien ok je reviens
en arrière c'est quoi ça es tu le
touches même pas à sa tête elle me suit
ces [ __ ] tête et me suit ces délits
la douloureuse jour tu me touches je te
passe au téton direct au quai des fois
ça fait très mal de retour dans la pièce
du début c'est quoi je dois faire des
allers retours entre de [ __ ] pièces et
avec important qui me regardent ça
l'histoire c'est ennuyant hop j'ai
horreur de ça c'est un truc de dingue le
jusque-là moynier je les embrasse se la
joue de lui comme non minier adiahénot
la ville note y avait une ong prix s'en
ressent liés aux eaux la valve de
décompression de téton dans un jeu
d'horreur na waie leurs morceaux je sois
pas habitués au fait que le mec qui
fasse dévier ans a changé la pizza et
vue hockey 1 hier ok ok american i'm
going to speak english and will cut your
bowles swiss knife own eyes off je
prédis knife parce qu'avec lucas hochart
on apprend les langues étrangères en
tout amusement aller où cette porte à
voilà c'est tout on va lire alors ses
marques et aux gaines
pas de décompression
aux maires non attendez c'est quoi ce
bordel wenger je dois juste des jams
hier tout le temps en la vendant des
taux du forfait je vais vous expliquer
qu'ainsi weiss qui adopte moi qui ai pas
parce que je mets gaye ok je vais vous
expliquer ce qui va se passer maintenant
je me cachais là dedans et en sortant je
serai plus là ok à mon avis là c'est une
sorte de labyrinthe ok il faut trouver
ou passer en revue les glyphes elles
sont rouges de l'autre côté ils ont tué
des gens
c'est quoi ça you can't escape jeu peut
m'échapper ah bah oui maintiennent porte
là bas tout est tellement plus simple
vous me faites pas peur vous me faites
pas peur vous avez des cendriers à la
place des yeux et je faisais peur des 4
- vous disparaissez tous fautifs
voilà c'est bien je suis pas très bien
cetto a encore moins avancés je ressors
votre soutien la mort allemand jour
j'arrive à apercevoir vos ondes
positives
ok on est de retour dans la pièce du
début donc quand on devient auront un ok
tu peux tu échappes aimé mais quoi mais
made in china
mélenchon mélodies mélanie méprisant
essaie de rassurer en disant des [ __ ]
de mots de l'alphabet quoi alors
français soit de l'alphabet ça veut rien
dire eh ben je me rassure comme je peux
hockey et vous me faisais même pas
s'agirait vraiment non je me cache pas
derrière ce casse de manière ridicule
fermez les yeux avec autant de james
kane ont écouté ça fait combien de temps
on n'a pas fait ça moi la sortie est
proche
non ce sont james caire oui ces tuyaux
en cas d'impact vous devez appeler thuir
glace hockey c'est extrêmement mauvais
comme rocky amputé il fait quoi ça c'est
moi quand je perds une game allait bien
arrête je suis à fleur de peau
aujourd'hui à vous savez problème de
filles de régler tout doux le come-back
anyways tu reviendras dans tous les cas
au kenya aucun problème avec ça moi
j'adore revenir au bas d'un coup le mur
ici broken ena kengo excusez moi j'ai un
peu l'accent anglais parce que je me
vient des states là bas j'ai pratiqué le
jeu d'horreur sept s'efforcent ainsi que
non mais j'ai dit oh oh yeah yeah yeah
on se retourne on est mort au caire à
christophe paille qui fera la balle de
moi c'est moi je dirais choses pas
avancer do you have no choice tu n'as
pas d'autre choix
massa pour le dira
on a bien manqué bien ok moi j'adore la
bière de hockey aura du monde on a vu
qu'on n'a jamais vu ça dans l'histoire
du gâteau il ya thomas savoir écouter ce
fan rimac gâteau le polygone et
franchement la joue la buse je juge à se
faire me faut une clé ok ok non samsung
n'a que 15 hockey là c'est ouvert ma vie
une clé quelque part ici à arrêter c'est
quoi ça c'est des yeux ado au pouvoir
c'est juste des boobs quoi j'ai juste là
il ya une petite note
ok je peux pas être avec mon bras comme
ça en raclant le sol non non il faut que
je passe devant les ailes à perdre son
maléfique bah oui on est plus à faire de
sa magnifique est disparu totalement
disparu je suis quand même méfiants dans
le doute si on se prend une en bus sans
frais chié attend c'est quoi c'est une
clé ou faire des capsules et oui ça
garde allume-cigare je sais pas tu ne
peux pas me fuir à leur tour dans le
court en larmes après avoir inscrit
morlaàs est sur le retour il y aura
inscrit meurt nous réagit pas ça ne t'a
teindra pas d'accord attends c'est quoi
ce délire on arrive au bout de la salle
et c'est au nom au nom j'ai eu peur face
aux olives et du coup j'ai fait
demi-tour sans m'en rendre compte
oh je suis la plus grosse merde de
youtube francophone [ __ ] j'ai haute au
maire grosse culture est ok blattmann
paca les personnes les biens aux plats
maintenant qu'on va tout l'effort du
conte à la clé est là il ya un problème
modélisation et ses chaudes non c'est
pour le cul nicki minaj ça je les
connais regardez moi savent le trou il
est comme ça tu peux mettre dix fois mes
fesses dans son droit au la clé dans les
toilettes j'adore oyez note là comme ça
d'un coup il a déposé leur parti le mec
je fais partie de toi y'a rien qui fait
partie de moi ok hormis peut-être et 20
euros vous fait peur les gars ça vous
fait peur à ces séances et la boîte cvt
vigiles ok i'm ok elle apporte au maire
stop ok alors je rends sur la note il y
aura marqué bien jouer tu as gagné ce
jeu est maintenant temps nous trop et
c'est mon monde
le to pick up flash lite à soyez pas des
mois j'ai une flash lite vous vous avez
rien à part des chars y en a une vilaine
crottes day 1 pour lucas pour lui cacher
a provoqué compris tabac pour aller au
bout du couloir sombre
musique sympa houba houba ce sont à la
fois du jeu je suis hyper déçue j'ai
adoré trop se faire cette vidéo avec
vous en plus mais je vais vraiment
beaucoup de plaisir sur ce jeu quoi
olala puis arrive c'est qu'on s'amuse
des choses passent vraiment vite
oula oula holla holla holla holla holla
hockey holla holla with them both hockey
en eau non mon gaza par e mail on a bien
oui bonjour
ok il va falloir se repérer d'accord
alors on se repère de manière efficace
je viens de là je viens du sud et
partout les chemins j'y reviendrai
cordialement alors vous êtes par là non
je suis foutu je suis morte je le sors
je le sens j'ai le couteau sous la gorge
je le sens et je sens aussi autre chose
sur mes testicules qui rentrent comme ça
dans mon ventre qui touche les ados
comme ça non non ce week-end le fennec
est de nous s'il te plait je ne vois
plus que des clones ça commençait à
l'école tu parles trop vite s'il vous
plaît monsieur lemay sens tous les mois
la clé laissez-moi mandat les deux
voulaient frais gagner l air et toutes
les nuits je pense à toi tout numérique
tu es jolie au monde d'une part aux
mondiaux ça sent la fin du leur désolé
j'ai envie de chanter aujourd'hui mais
d'ailleurs je me reconvertir dersoir un
album aux fêtes pré commander les sur
itunes s'il est dispo il ya un truc qui
va me sauter dessus d'un peu de temps ce
sera quelqu'un qui vienne du sud quand
je vois tout ce qui brille la bartère
givet european it tué piégé dedans au
cyclo que mais oui
melzer a sound of dream house était
bilingue aussi alors le texte parle de
cauchemar
une personne en proie troupe de
cauchemar aurait du mal à passer par les
tâches quotidiennes donc c'était le
manque de sommeil causés par les rêves
effrayants gênerait l'individu
d'accomplir tous les jours son travail
de manière efficace et correcte en
partenariat avec google traduction aussi
en fuite sur l'album serait que je vois
les choses il ya 37 19 cas et morges et
spatiaux de la plus c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas la vidéo comme ben j'ai
bien kiffé or c'est pas très beau
graphiquement mais je sais pas le
l'ambiance et james ya été assez bien
foutu j'ai bien aimé ont besoin d'une
paire de sarobi fille mais après avoir
regardé un certain très bientôt deux
prochaines vidéos elle est la voix va se
rétablir en fait pas chez tout le monde
merci pif
[Musique]